today's webinar will discuss preclinical
optical imaging
of infectious diseases the content was
generated by dr calvin francis
and the presenter is dr julie sabrina
perkinelmer
provides a wide variety of detection and
imaging systems
in order to analyze increasing cellular
complexity
one can use the lab chip envision victor
systems
or nsite for dna rna and protein
analysis
and then move into live cell imaging
using the movie site
which is a live cell imaging system
designed to operate
inside your cell culture incubator this
enables you to maintain your cells under
optimal conditions
and perform a wide range of assays in a
variety of culture vessels
for imaging cells the apparatus cls high
content system
combines speed and sensitivity with the
powerful and intuitive data analysis
you've come to trust
from the apartment platform
the opera phoenix plus high content
screening system is the premier confocal
solution for today's most demanding high
content applications
the phoenix plus is specifically
designed for high throughput high
content assays
phenotypic screening and fast response
assays
such as calcium flux or patio myocytes
the conflictility of operetta cls and
upper phoenix provides focused light
penetration
further into today's complex 3d cell
model systems
including organelle chip models
finally as far as model organisms where
our discussion will be focused today
broken elmer provides a variety of in
vivo imaging platforms
as well as informatics and automation
solutions
since this webinar will focus on optical
imaging
we wanted to point out some of our
preclinical imaging platforms
we have an array of systems designed to
suit a variety of imaging needs
from benchtop systems voluminous series
which can image
2d bioluminescence and fluorescence and
some are equipped
with an x-ray overlay
we also have systems the iris spectrum
series
which can produce both 2d planar and 3d
tomographic images
as seen here our quantum micro ct system
provides a high resolution scanning
solution
for those of you unfamiliar when imaging
bioluminescent bacteria or cells the
basic methodology as shown here
is if you're dealing with bacteria you
can use a 5-gene operon with a cassette
that has both luciferase
and aldehyde synthesis genes so you can
engineer bacteria which will glow
constitutively
or under the control of a desired
promoter
perkanomer's own kevin francis was one
of the first people to engineer the
operon to work in gram-positive bacteria
if you put this into transposons you can
engineer virtually any bacteria to
monitor gene regulation from these
different strains
of course you can use a repertoire of
different genes which you will see today
such as firefly luciferase and
nanoluciferase which can also be
engineered into viruses
once you've engineered the luciferase or
fluorescent protein into for example a
capsid of a virus
or a genome of bacteria these variants
or cells can be put into an animal model
these animals can then be imaged using
our ibis platforms
one of which you see here the avid
spectrum ct
which can actually image up to 10 mice
at once in 2d
the image at the bottom right comes from
imperial college
with james collins and gad frankel and
shows citrobacter rodentium
which can serve as a model for
inflammatory bowel disorders
there is a vast array of optical
reporters to choose from
the most common luciferase for in vivo
imaging is firefly luciferase
and this was the first one to be used in
cancer studies and has since been used
routinely across many different disease
areas
before nanolucid phrase the smallest
luciferase was developed
the next smallest luciferases were
gaussia and vanilla
these luciferases do not require atp so
you can actually use both firefly
and these atp independent reporters in
combination
to report on the metabolic state of
cells
in addition a very wide range of
fluorescent proteins can be used
in the ios platforms as you can see here
in this image from the late roger chen
fluorescent proteins range from blue all
the way to the far red
there are pros and cons to using
luciferases and fluorescent proteins
luciferases will have much higher
sensitivity in vivo
while fluorescent proteins have high
utility both in vitro and
x vivo in terms of things like facts and
microscopy
recently some researchers are using
fusion proteins for example by fusing
something like nanoluciferase
to a fluorescent protein you would
actually get two emission peaks
one for manuloque and one from the
fluorescent protein which was actually
excited directly by the nanoluciferase
resulting in a very bright emission
and allows for greater tissue
penetration of the light
other reporters that can be imaged in
the iris platforms
are based on hemi luminescence cherenkov
luminescence
phosphorescence and a wide variety of
fluorescent dyes
variants of fiberflow luciferase have
been engineered wherein the peak
emission is shifted into the red end of
the visible spectrum
in order to increase depth penetration
however in certain instances this can
result in a reduced quantum yield
alternatively variants of luciferin
substrate have been generated to try to
improve individual performance
without necessarily optimizing enzyme
binding
recent improvement approaches as seen in
this study from uc irvine
involved generating mutant luciferase
libraries
and screening for orthogonal pairs
here an initial on-plate screen
identified functional luciferase mutants
and secondary screening was then
performed for orthogonality with other
mutants
and luciferin analogs
a great example of this type of strategy
is shown by the stellar light production
of the aka loop in akulu mean system
this study published in science out of
reichen
the tokyo institute of technology kyoto
university
and the university of electro
communications shows the vastly improved
sensitivity
of bioluminescence imaging using this
novel reporting system
in both mice and marmosets
you can clearly see higher light
intensity with the akka system
compared to firefly luciferase when
imaging the same numbers of cells
both in the lungs and the brain of mice
further the sensitivity of the system is
highlighted by the ability to image
bioluminescence
in the brain of a marmoset after a five
millimeter deep
injection of an adeno-associated virus
expressing
this reporter
today's discussion is going to focus on
the imaging infectious disease however
we'd like to point out that the imaging
possibilities using the ibis platform
are virtually endless in fact there are
over
12 000 peer-reviewed publications that
utilize the iris
a small sample of the biological
applications published using our
technology are shown here
from agro micro tartar plates to plants
to insects and fish
to mice of course and other ex-vivo
examples
to begin our discussion on using optical
imaging for imaging infectious disease
we'd like to start with this publication
from a group at nya emery in wisconsin
this is a flu study where they used
nanoluciferase which was necessary
because the flu genome is very small
and thus if firefly luciferase were used
its size would cause viral attenuation
the small size of neta loop proves to be
advantageous here
even though it is very blue it is also
very bright allowing for deeper tissue
imaging
as you can see coming from the lungs
in this publication they performed both
vaccine and immunotherapy studies
of which the immunotherapy study is
shown here
in the middle row you can see where they
used
immunotherapy as a prophylaxis so they
administer the antibody before the
infection was administered
you also see an example of using the
antibody as a therapy
during the infection both instances
showed reduction of the viral load
as compared to control which is of
course able to be visualized using the
ivis imaging technology
here is another example with both
luciferase and fluorescent protein
engineered into the virus
this gives the best of both worlds they
can use the bioluminescence to easily
determine plaque
forming units in the lungs in vivo and
xvivo will be able to use the
fluorescent recorder
to be able to determine spatially where
the disease is located in the lungs
and then of course they could also use
the proteins in high resolution
microscopy which is very common with
these reporters
this study was performed at the
university of rochester in the animal
health center
in madrid
here is another example highlighting the
versatility of optical imaging
you can label a virus via genetic
engineering and put the reporter
molecule inside the viral capsid
so that when the rna or dna is
incorporated into the cell
you get a bioluminescent signal or you
could engineer it so that a smaller
reporter such as nanoluciferase or
gaussian luciferase
is on the outside of the capsid in order
to track the baryons
this example actually used pro-nuclear
micro-injection to engineer the animal
itself
here they were able to image a cytokine
pathway in the lungs
using luciferase and monitor
inflammation in the lungs that
correlated with viral progression
with the advancements in reporter
development since this paper was
published
you could even perform dual imaging by
labeling the virus with nanoluciferase
in order to monitor the disease
progression along with the host response
as shown here
in this publication done at xenogen they
used an
alternative to transgenic models which
can be very expensive
and laborious to produce they took two
different genetic reporter constructs
using loop 2 and fuse them to tnf alpha
nf kappa b and interleukin-8 so they
have both cytokine and chemopine
examples
they deliver the constructs with jet pei
into the tail vein of the animal
under low pressure this then transformed
the lung epithelium
and the animal stay transformed for a
few months
at first you can see background for
about a week or two
until the background signals are to
disappear around
the two-week mark upon delivery of
libopolysaccharide
to the lungs you can immediately see
cytokine and chemokine signal returned
via bioluminescence imaging what this
means is that you can transform animals
such as mice
rats and ferrets with these constructs
and monitor different genetic pathways
in the lungs
this is a promising and cost-effective
alternative to transgenic animal models
this example is very pertinent to the
state of the world today
and is from the inrs and university of
quebec
this is showing the imaging of a
coronavirus infection but it is in fact
not sars uh copic 2.
it is causing a neuroinvasive infection
in this mouse model
you may recall that some of the symptoms
of copenhagen are a loss of taste and
smell
and this can be an early indicator that
the cns is being affected by the virus
in rare cases these viruses can spread
to the brain and cause encephalitis
this example uses firefly luciferase
engineered into the virus
as the coronavirus genome is larger than
the flu
in this case the authors were able to
track the viral tropism in the animal
and also use microscopy to show exactly
how it was moving
in the cns
in this study from harvard medical
university and speaking university
they wanted to intuitively see how
enterovirus infected these animals
because of the small size of the
enterovirus
they are very hard to engineer so they
instead took a different approach
where they took firefly luciferase and
integrated
the c3 proteolytic cleavage site into it
so when the cleavage site is in between
the nnc terminus of the luciferase it is
non-functional and you would not see any
bioluminescent light
but when the site is cleaved the protein
is able to refold
and become functional again and would
thus produce bioluminescence
they then introduced the split construct
intracerebrally and infected some of the
animals with enterovirus 71.
in the sham animals which have received
the construct but no virus
no luciferase signal is seen but animals
that have the construct and that were
infected with the enterovirus
you were able to see luciferase signal
due to the c3 cleavage
by the virus this is a clever way to
monitor the virus without actually
engineering it
zika virus is a serious disease that
causes brain abnormalities during early
development
however a glimmer of hope surrounding
this virus comes from research out of
brazil
that also uses the average technology
the group hypothesized that since zika
virus preferentially infects
neural progenitor cells then maybe you
could act as an oncolytic agent against
cns embryonic tumors that are
particularly aggressive
after implantation of both
medulloblastoma
shown in the daoi in usp13
and atypical territoid the usp7 cells
the authors were able to monitor the
oncolytic effect of a zika virus as the
tumor cells expressed firefly luciferase
it was seen that distinct cns tumor
types may have different sensitivity to
the zika virus as shown
here the daoi versus the other two cell
types
and in some of the cell types more
sensitive to the zika virus
you could see clearance in as fast as
two to three weeks
so now we will move on to some examples
into bacterial imaging
this is one of the first examples of an
x-ray overlay with optical images
both using bioluminescent and
fluorescence
this is using a dual-labeled salmonella
which expresses both bacterial
luciferase or lux
and the m cherry fluorescent protein
and this will allow for the
visualization of a gi infection
the x-ray overlay after the addition of
a barium sulfate contrast agent
allows for a very nice delineation of
the gi tract
and a better anatomical understanding of
where the optical signals are coming
from
this work is from imperial college
showing a beautiful image from the ibis
spectrum ct
the 3d image on the left shows by
luminescent citrobacterodentium
colonizing to the sql patch the animal
was administered a ct contrast agent
allowing for exquisite anatomical
visualization using micro ct
co-registration with the 3d
reconstruction
of the optical bioluminescence signal
the co-registration
enables better understanding of
infection localization and signal
intensity
at depth
this is an example of a uti island
nephritis
model where bioluminescent e coli were
administered directly into the bladder
of mice in these types of studies
typically only about half of the animals
will develop phylonephritis
however upon inspection of the 2d
bioluminescent images
it may appear that both mice do in fact
exhibit
pyelonephritis the animal on the left
was image in 3d using the avid spectrum
ct
you can clearly see the e coli in the
ureter and one kidney which is expected
of this model
around the two week mark when the animal
on the right
was imaged in 3d you can see that the
bioluminescent signal is actually coming
from the gi tract
indicating that the animal likely
infected itself
after ingesting waste tainted materials
the importance of 3d imaging with ct
co-registration becomes very clear here
as the images taken in 2d look very
similar to each other
but in fact are completely different
underneath the surface
this final example is a study from ucla
university medical center groningen and
herkin um
utilizing the spectrum ct to image a
bioluminescent staphorious biofilm
on a pin implanted in the l4 vertebrae
along with a fluorescently labeled
antibody 1d9680
that specifically binds to the
staphorious bacteria
here we are able to visualize the
bioluminescent bacteria
shown in blue along with the
co-localization of the fluorescently
labeled antibody
1d9 shown in orange
due to the broad range of filters in the
ibus spectrum ct
we were also able to distinctly
visualize vancomycin
that was labeled with an 800 nanometer
fluorescent reporter
and we saw what was to be expected that
it works well in the short term
but in the long term tends to break down
and move around the animal
thank you for attending our webinar
covering optical preclinical imaging
of infectious disease